medical experts are voicing deep concern
over the extreme transportation
requirements of a major new coronavirus
vaccine for the u.s
fires has applied for emergency
authorization of its jab but
analysts question whether distributing
it at the necessary minus 70 degrees
is even realistic the reality is there
has never been a drug that requires
storage at this temperature
it's a logistical nightmare for rural
communities but no one is immune to the
challenges distributing the vaccine
posed for the medical industry
the whole infrastructure to do the
distribution i don't see that coming
together in a
rational fashion it's so cacapinis
it could work out in a decent way
it doesn't appear that it is so i'm
worried about vaccine distribution
not going uh to the right people
and not going at full speed i can't
predict the numbers
but wow it is a dysfunctional
set of people right at the moment few
cargo companies have the capacity to
transport goods at minus 70 which is
colder than the north south pole in fact
many firms don't even have the
facilities to do it at -20
and that's far from the only logistical
challenge expected particularly
in poorer and remote areas the vaccine
also needs special deep-free suitcases
which can be used for just 10 days
it also requires dry ice which is a
hazardous
material and few hospitals and
pharmacies have ultra cold freezers
yet the company behind the jab remains
confident
we have already produced more than 20
million doses
in our warehouses and we continue as we
speak producing more and more
this is why we said that by the end of
the year which is in
how many five weeks we expect to have 50
million doses
that we can distribute to the world we
spoke to a senior clinical lecturer at
britain's university of exeter medical
school
he says it's important for different
vaccines to be created across the world
to provide choice
it's very important to maintain what you
would call the cold
chain extremely important otherwise you
are injecting people with
substandard or denatured vaccine and it
is a waste of time
resources and everything else so it is
very
very important to make sure that the
vaccines when they leave
the laboratory where it is made to where
the patient is going to receive it
is maintained always at the right
temperature
you either have facilities to transport
them
or you use other vaccines and there is
no reason to suspect that the other
vaccines are inferior
once they're licensed they're licensed
and we know that they are good enough
for the job
therefore it's very good to know that
there are also
other vaccines made by other platforms
also coming on stream
in given time
you